oui
bonjour sandrine bonjour damien presse
dans le monde qui revient d'abord sur
sur ce premier anniversaire de la
présidence bagdad oui c'est vrai et les
titres de la presse ce matin ne sont pas
très élogieux beaucoup d'adjectifs qui
le prouvent regarder cette une sombre de
la croix ce matin joe biden est enlisée
depuis un an au pouvoir le président
américain est fragilisé par sa trop
faible majorité au congrès nous disent
journal catholique qui parles d'un
anniversaire morose lui qui promettait
de réconcilier l'amérique avec elle-même
et de vaincre la pandémie de kobe 19 et
bien un an après il ya plus de morts que
sous donald trump nous disent quotidien
et puis il ya aussi la hausse des prix
on en a parlé en qui affecte pas mal le
moral des américains le prix à la pompe
a bondi de plus de 40 9% en un an même
constat de déception dans un autre
journal français le figaro joe biden
malgré une immense expérience au sénat
et bien il est dans une impasse lui qui
avait été saluée pourtant comme le
nouveau franklin roosevelt et son mandat
comme celui d'un new deal est bien un an
après on le compare plutôt à jimmy
carter l'infortuné président nous dit on
ici idéaliste mais plutôt maladroit
humilié d'ailleurs par la prise d'otage
de téhéran joe biden a surestimé ses
capacités politiques ici en pointe
notamment son retrait calamiteuse
d'afghanistan et puis sur le dossier
ukrainien et bien aux lieux nous dit ce
journal d'établir une certaine stabilité
prévisibilité avec la russie et bien on
a plutôt l'impression que joe biden n'a
pas jusqu'ici donné l'impression de
savoir à trop quoi faire et qu'en dit la
presse étrangère eh bien on va regarder
par exemple du côté de la presse
chinoise le global times ce qui est un
peu la voix de pékin est bien le dresse
un bilan de la première année de bail de
nos pouvoirs synonyme ici de déception
voyez-vous lé dans la lutte contre le
coc vide ou encore face à la promesse de
guérison d'une société divisée joe biden
nous dit ce journal n'a pas fait mieux
que donald trump finalement on observe
que les tensions avec la russie et la
chine restent inchangées voire
s'intensifie sur le dossier avec
l'ukraine où avec taiwan l'espoir
d'amiens vient plutôt de la presse
américaine le new york times publie ici
un article intitulé
d'haydn peut encore sauver sa présidence
ici on lui conseille et bien de changer
d'équipé notamment son chef de cabinet
en effet cette première année aurait été
plutôt marquée par une certaine
incompétence politique de ce côté là on
s'interroge notamment comment joe biden
a t'il pu tenir son discours rendus en
géorgie sur cette réforme du droit de
vote des minorités s'attaquer aux
républicains sans vérifier au préalable
plus la sénatrice kirsten cinéma lui
resterait fidèle et puis comment à un
accord avec un autre sénateur john chine
n'a pas été trouvé en ce qui concerne sa
réforme phare bill de bach better on va
regarder et bien un descendant le
charlotte observer requis ici signé
kevin fire ce qui résume bien cet
anniversaire en vous le voyez je n'ai
jamais résolu tous les bugs tous les
problèmes locaux vides avec tous ces
variants au congrès on le voit ici à
mitch mcconnell et puis dans son propre
camp jordan chine et cinéma et puis dans
la presse aussi ce nouveau procès en
allemagne après la condamnation à
perpétuité d'un ancien haut gradé du
renseignement syriens et une semaine
c'est un nouveau procès qui s'est ouvert
ce mercredi oui après un ancien colonel
des services de renseignements syriens
condamné à la perpétuité la semaine
dernière c'est donc un deuxième procès
lié aux exactions attribuées au régime
de bachar al assad qui s'est ouvert
mercredi en allemagne cette fois c'est
un médecin syrien qui est jugé c'est en
une du quotidien l'orient le jour alors
cet homme s'appelle alaa moussa il a 36
ans il est accusé d'avoir torturé au
moins dix huit opposants du régime de
bachar al assad et d'en avoir tué au
moins l'un d'entre eux des faits qui se
sont déroulés à homs entre 2011 et 2012
dans des hôpitaux militaires le der
spiegel revient aussi sur la vie de ce
médecin qui a obtenu d'ailleurs le
statut de réfugié en 2015 en allemagne
il a vécu nous dit ce journal
tranquillement pendant cinq ans à
continuer à exercer son métier de
chirurgien orthopédique dont plusieurs
établissements en allemagne le journal
indique que ce procès ne portera pas
seulement sur la torture d'état en syrie
mais aussi sur le rôle de ces hôpitaux
dans la machine à tuer de la chaire al
assad dans l'acte d'accusation damian
parle de civils ligoté attaché au lit
presque nue et les yeux bandés c'est
assez terrible à dire je rigole merci
beaucoup sans une grand-messe merci à
vous d'avoir choisi françois